REUVEN LAX: Hi everyone.
My name is Reuven.
I'm an engineer at Google.
This is my colleague Marwa
from Product Management.
And we're here to talk to you
today about big data analysis
and how to make it fast.
So those of you who've
done this before,
who've written big
data analysis before,
know how painful it
can be sometimes.
You spend a lot of time writing
your configuration files,
managing how much
parallelism you need,
managing pools of machines.
You often spend
more time doing this
then you actually spend
writing the code that
does your analysis.
We want you to be
able to move very,
very quickly from concept,
from sort of your white board
design of what you want
your analysis to be,
to a production code that
runs and runs at scale.
These pipelines also
need to be really fast.
The world we live in is
very, very quickly changing.
And you need to keep up with
real time trends in your data.
Your pipeline needs to be
able to stream in current data
and constantly update its
results as the data comes in.
So to allow you to
solve these problems,
I'm really excited to give a
peek at Google Cloud Dataflow.
Those of you who
were at the keynote
yesterday and
actually stayed there
until the end of the keynote
already got a peak of Dataflow
in action.
So what is Dataflow?
Dataflow is a system for
building big and fast data
analysis pipelines.
The way it works is you write
a sequence of logical data
transformations that are easy
to write and very intuitive
that specify the
analysis you want to do.
You submit this to
the data flow service.
And it runs for you.
It's fully managed.
So it runs for you on as many
machines as are necessary
in order to run your pipeline.
All the configuration, all the
parallelism, all of the tuning,
it's all taken care of for you.
And you don't need to spend
a lot of time thinking
about that when you're
writing your program.
So let's look at a quick
example that uses Dataflow.
So a feature that
you're familiar
with from many websites out
there is auto completing words.
So for instance,
Google does this.
As you start typing
a search, we auto
complete and give
search suggestions.
And also Twitter does this.
If you start typing
in a hash tag,
Twitter will automatically
start suggesting hashtags
that you might actually
be trying to type.
So what does it take to build
an application like this?
And let's focus now on this
Twitter example of auto
completing hash tags.
Well, there's a front
end that displays this.
And the front end is
all about displaying
it well and
intuitively and making
it easy for the user to use.
But the front end
needs a back end
to serve up the data, to
tell the front end, OK,
the user has typed in "ar."
What are the suggestions
that I should
display right now for "ar"?
And this is something that's
been traditionally painful
building these data models
and keeping them up to date.
And this is particularly what
Dataflow makes easy to do.
So for this auto
completing of hashtag let's
start off by thinking
about what we would need.
So what we need to do,
this is a prefix model.
What the users are typing
are prefixes of hashtags
that they want until they've
typed the entire hashtag,
you have increasing prefixes.
So we want something like this.
Actually, unfortunately,
the slides
seem to have scrolled off
the screen a little bit.
I'm not sure why.
But what's missing here
is on the left side here,
I'm putting "ar," "arg," "arge."
And we're showing that
the suggestions for our
these prefixes.
And you see as the user types
in more and more characters--
we've colored the
prefix that they've
typed-- the suggestions
keep refining.
So this is the model
we want to build.
This is the data we want
for our application.
Let's think for a
minute how we would
go about logically
building this model.
I'm going to start
off with a batch
analysis over a
bunch of static data.
For instance, all the tweets
that happened yesterday.
Then later I'll show
how we will modify
this to process streaming
data to keep up with changing
hashtags as they start
and stop printing.
So I know where
I'm starting from.
I know where I'm going to.
I'm starting from this
big batch of tweets
that happened yesterday.
And at the end, I want
to produce predictions
that I can write out somewhere
where my app can read it.
So we want to start off
by reading these tweets.
So let's read.
So we redid a whole
bunch of tweets.
Argentina scores,
Armenia versus Argentina,
which is not a real game by
the way-- my art project.
And for reference, I
put down the models
that I actually want
to write out here,
so I know where I'm going to
as I'm building up my pipeline.
So I want these prefix models.
I want models that
map every prefix
to a list of suggestions.
So I'm trying to auto
complete hashtags.
So I actually don't
care about anything
in the tweet that's
not a hashtag.
So let's extract the hashtags.
And now I have Argentina,
Armenia, Argentina, and so on.
Next step is, I know that I
need to rank these hashtags
and decide which are
the most popular ones.
So let's count them.
So I'm counting here how often
every unique hashtag happened
yesterday.
And in this fake
data set up here,
Argentina happened 5
million times yesterday,
Armenia 2 million
times and so on.
Now, looking back here at
my results I want to get,
I'm reminded that I want
prefixes of all these hashtags.
So let's expand
all the prefixes.
Let's take every one
of these hashtags
and explode it into all the
prefixes of the hashtags.
So expand the prefixes.
And now this is what we have.
I've expanded them into
a set of key value pairs,
where the keys are all the
prefixes of every word that
was a hashtag.
And the values are the original
hashtags that had this prefix.
And I'm keeping around
this ranking information,
these counts.
Because we are almost here.
The only problem is that
we have too many results.
A is going to have
millions of results.
And we only want a few results
to suggest to the user.
So there's only
one step left to do
to get from here to
my actual suggestions.
And that's to just take the top
three results per key, using
this ranking that I've
attached to it from the count.
And now I have all
the data I need
to do this prefix suggestion,
this hashtag suggestion.
All that's left to do is
write it out somewhere
and for my application to read
that data as the user types it.
So we just went through
this in the design phase.
We wrote a sequence of
logical data transformations
that made a lot of sense and
got us from a batch of tweets
to a set of predictions.
What does it take to go
from this to actual code?
And with Dataflow the
answer is not much.
This is the actual code
I would write in order
to run this pipeline.
So notice that the
lines of code here
are matching one to one
with these logical steps
that I wrote here.
Read, extract tags,
count and so on.
So most of my time here
was just spent designing.
I spent time on the
whiteboard or here
on the slide designing what
the pipeline would look like.
And once I was finished with
designing, at that point,
writing the code was really
easy and took very little time.
I want to quickly point
out these two lines here
that say ParDo under my
extract and expand prefixes.
This is how you insert
user defined code
into a Dataflow pipeline.
So a ParDo, we call it ParDo
because they are parallel.
It's a little bit
of code you write
that runs in parallel over
all the records coming out
of the previous stage
and transforms them
into records for the next stage.
Those of you who have
used MapReduce before,
just something that we invented
at Google about a little
over 10 years ago,
I believe, might
recognize this as very
similar to a mapper function.
Although Dataflow is far more
general than just MapReduce.
These ParDo functions you write
are usually very short though.
So for this expand
prefixes, this
is the ParDo for
expand prefixes.
It's a short snippet of
code that takes in a word
and just iterates over
the word and outputs
every prefix of the word.
So now you have your code here.
You could run it locally on your
machine with some sample data,
iterate on it,
debug it, keep going
until it appears to do
exactly what you want.
And then you hit
the point where you
want to run this on your
actual big data at scale.
And that's where
Dataflow comes in.
So you take your code, and now
instead of running it locally
on your machine, you submit it
to the Google Cloud Dataflow
Service.
Once it's submitted to the
Google Cloud Dataflow Service,
it starts running for you
and processing all your data.
The Dataflow service also
gives you a monitoring console,
which allows you to monitor
this data while it's processing.
It let's you see
progress of your data
and helps you debug problems in
your pipeline as they happen.
This is a simple and
intuitive monitoring console
that matches one to one to
the lines of code you wrote.
So we're not giving you
these big blocks saying,
something is wrong
in your pipeline.
We're giving you,
here's what's happening
with your extract tags.
Here's what's happening
with your account.
Here's what's happening with
your expand prefixes and so on.
So this is all very
simple in terms
of the use of the pipeline.
You don't have to do
much to use this service.
But behind the
scenes, a little more
has to happen to make this work.
So here's your view.
You write your code and
submit it to Cloud Dataflow
and just watch it via
this monitoring console.
However, this programming
model we gave you
allowed you to write
very fine-grained steps.
You're writing
your extract tags.
And then you're counting.
And then you're
expanding each prefix.
If we actually ran
these as written
separately on all of
Twitter's data from yesterday,
it would take way
too long to finish.
So in order for this to
work, we need an optimizer.
The optimizer takes in the
code you've written, determines
which lines of code can actually
run together as one group,
rearranges things a
little bit into something
that can run efficiently, and
produces this optimized program
on the right here
to actually execute.
Older systems actually
didn't provide an optimizer.
So when you use those
systems, you usually
had to hand optimize your code.
So for example, MapReduce again,
if you're using MapReduce,
you have to spend a lot of time
thinking which lines of code
should run in the
first MapReduce
and which lines of code should
run in the second MapReduce.
We let you just write
things logically
as they would work
in your application.
And we do this
optimization for you.
You need a scheduler.
In reality, this is
running on a lot of data.
This is running on big data.
In order to process it, you
need many VMs, many machines
to process this data.
You need to schedule reading
stuff in from Google Cloud
Storage, distributing
the Google Cloud Storage
data on to all these worker
machines, onto all these VMS,
getting data off the VMs,
and back into your output,
which appears also on
Google Cloud Storage.
You may need to expand.
Halfway through
the pipeline, you
may decide we actually
need more machines.
We don't have enough.
You may need to add some
machines to this pool.
You need a scheduler
to run this.
And you don't want to have
to configure it yourself.
So with Google Cloud Dataflow,
we're fully managing this.
So all of this lives
behind the cloud.
You don't have to be
aware of all these things
that need to happen when
you submit your pipeline
to be executed.
Now we believe in
transparency here.
So these worker machines here,
our Google Compute Engine VMs,
so you are free
to SSH into them.
Take a look at your
actual code running
and see what's happening.
But this is never
something that you
have to do in order
to use Dataflow.
So we talked about
doing this in batch.
But we're talking about
Twitter hashtags here.
Twitter hashtags change
very, very quickly.
A hashtag that is
trending now may no longer
be trending in an hour.
If we wait until the
next day to process
yesterday's batch of
data to give suggestions,
our application is
going to be displaying
very out of date information.
It will be displaying--
We won't be displaying the
current trending hashtags.
We'll be display hashtags
that were trending yesterday.
We need to actually keep
up with the current data.
So let's stream it.
Let's take this batch
pipeline that we just wrote
and change it to process
streaming data to process
the hashtag information
as it's happening.
So how do we jump this gap?
This sounds like a
difficult problem.
And in the past, it
actually often required
rewriting your entire
pipeline from scratch
using a completely
different framework.
And with Dataflow,
we make this easy
and don't require you
to rewrite the pipeline.
So what needs to change?
Let's think about
that for a second.
Your reads and writes.
We were before reading a static
set of files containing tweets
from Google Cloud Storage.
Now, instead, we want to
read it from a streaming
source providing tweets.
So for that we're using
Google Cloud Pub/Sub.
Google Cloud Pub/Sub is
a new product from Google
that just went into
limited preview that
provides a reliable many to
many message delivery channel.
And here it integrates
with Dataflow
in order to allow you to
constantly stream data in
and out of a
pipeline, essentially
to create a data flow pipeline,
a data analysis pipeline, that
never finishes-- an
infinite pipeline tracking
trends in real time.
The other thing
we need to do when
we write a streaming pipeline,
a pipeline that never finishes,
is we need to think
about the time element.
We don't want the tweets that
happen last week to still
be influencing the suggestions
that we're providing.
So we want somehow to
age out the old data
and prioritize the new
data that's coming in.
So continuing my example of the
fake Argentina-Armenia game,
here's a graph of suggestions
that may begin with "ar."
As you see, for a
while a lot of people
were searching for argyle.
And over time that
doesn't change.
But as this game
begins and ends,
the data of people tweeting
about Argentina and Armenia
and the game starts trending.
And after the game ends,
excited and disappointed fans
start tweeting.
And then eventually
over time, as the game
fades into the past and
people forget about it,
we would expect this graph
to start converging back
to something looking
like the beginning.
So what do we want to do
to modify our pipeline
to keep track of
what's going on now?
So we're going to
use a sliding window.
So if we take a
window of time that
keeps advancing
as time advances,
we want our pipeline to
track data within this window
and immediately forget about
data before the window.
So we're prioritizing the
stuff that's happening now.
So what does it take to go
from this to actual code
to change my pipeline to be
a proper streaming pipeline?
Again, with Dataflow,
very, very little.
So here is the pipeline we wrote
earlier, the batch pipeline
for tweet analysis.
And let's change this to
be a streaming pipeline.
So first of all, our
core logic that's
doing our actual analysis
doesn't have to change.
Extracting hashtags,
counting, expanding prefixes,
there's nothing streaming or
batch specific about that.
So let's leave that alone.
We no longer want to read data
from Google Cloud Storage,
we want to instead
read data from Pub/Sub
from our streaming source.
So let's change that.
Now we're reading and
running data from Pub/Sub.
How do we add this sliding
window to age out old data?
Well, it takes a whole
extra line of code
to do that with Dataflow.
and there we go.
We add a Bucket.by
SlidingWindows of 60 minutes.
And now our entire pipeline is
processing on the last window.
And data older than
the window is aged out.
Dataflow provides far
more sophisticated buckets
than this as well, although
the SlidingWindow bucket is
often sufficient for most needs.
Changing the code here
was very, very simple.
We did very little to go
from batch to streaming.
But behind the scenes, again,
a lot more has to happen.
So this is our behind
the scenes picture again.
But now it's been
modified to show what's
happening for a
streaming pipeline.
Our optimizer has to change.
The optimization algorithms for
optimizing a streaming pipeline
are different than the
optimization algorithms
for optimizing a batch pipeline.
Scheduling is also slightly
different between streaming
and batch.
Instead of managing a
bunch of static files
in Google Cloud Storage,
we now have that we now
have to manage Pub/Sub
topics and subscriptions.
Our worker VMs need a
little bit of storage
in order to keep track
of this bucketing in data
to see what data is seen so far.
However, again, the
point of Dataflow
is even though many things
have to change in the back end
to go from batch to streaming,
you are insulated from this.
You use a programming
model that's
focused on the what you
want to do to the data
and not as focused on
the how you want to do it
to your data, which means
that changing this how,
changing the batch analysis to
a stream analysis, is simple.
And you don't have to write a
completely different program.
So let's take a
quick look at what
this actual running pipeline is.
This is this monitoring UI
that I hinted at earlier.
And this is this actual
pipeline running right now.
So as I scroll
through it, you'll
see that all of these
boxes correspond exactly
to the code I write.
I have a bucket.by an
extract tags, account.
If you look for a
second, you'll see
that extract tags, the
data coming out of count
is lower data rate then
coming out of extract tags,
because it's coalescing
all unique tags.
But then after we go
out of expand prefixes,
the data blows up from
1,200 to about 11,000.
Because we're taking
every word and fanning it
out to all of its prefixes.
This is also a
place where I would
look for problems
in my pipeline.
So if there was a problem, if
the data out of expand prefixes
dropped to zero, I
would know that there
was a problem in
expand prefixes.
And I should go and look
at that part of my code.
I can also hover over
these edges here.
And I can see that this edge
between into extract tags, here
is the total records
we've seen so far.
And it's currently lagging about
between four and seven seconds
behind real time.
So here we have a really
quick App Engine app
I threw together that is
listening to the Pub/Sub output
stream of this
data flow pipeline
and using it give suggestions.
So I had it prefilled with "b."
Right now there's a game going
on between Germany and the US.
So I'm going to type in
"germ" and see what we get.
And here we go.
Germany, Germany for World
Cup, Germany versus USA.
If we kept watching
this long enough,
we would see these
suggestions constantly refresh
and change as the
Dataflow pipeline keeps
giving new suggestions based
off the Twitter input data.
So now I'm going to introduce
Marwa again, our product
manager who's going to talk
to you a little bit more
about the Dataflow product
and various use cases.
MARWA MABROUK: So hello.
I hope after all
the details we've
covered, you would
agree that this
is a new dawn for
analyzing real time data,
especially if it's very
large in size like stream,
like Twitter data.
And per that, this seems like
something also that's reachable
and that you could start using.
So to go and
summarize the details
that you've just seen, which
Reuven has just showed you,
we have two very
important things
that we need to remember.
The first one is that
solving a problem
uses a logical
sequence of thinking.
And that writing code
should follow that
without having to
compromise efficiency.
You shouldn't have to twist
how you think in order
to write code that is efficient.
You can write the code the
way you think and depend
on the system to do the
optimization on your behalf.
Additionally, when
you are writing
code for parallel
processing, you
don't have to take into
account the parallel
processing aspects themselves.
We've seen the custom code.
It writes through
a simple data type
that you don't have to take
into account what is really
happening when the parallel
processing is taking place.
Also we've seen that
model allows you not
to worry about
deploying a framework,
setting it up, optimizing
it, fine tuning it.
All of that is
inherently taken care of.
However, it is not a black box.
You can still have
full visibility
into what is happening
within the system.
So that was the first point.
The second point that we
see is that your data logic,
whether you're running
it in batch or streaming,
is the same.
And switching between
batch and streaming
should be pretty seamless
by just switching
the data input
and the data sync.
And it happens very
easily and quickly.
And you can do all of that
using Google Cloud Dataflow.
So when you're starting to build
an application or a solution,
typically developers
have a lot on their mind.
They have to worry about
the infrastructure,
where the application will
run, what kind of frameworks
are included to
provide the features
and meet the
requirements in addition
to the UI and visibility
and how to engage
the users-- a whole lot
of things to think about.
So what we're seeing
today simply allows
you not to worry about
infrastructure management
anymore.
You don't have to worry about
how parallel processing will
happen and how to
tune that yourself.
You don't have to
do that anymore.
And additionally, you
don't have to go hunting
through logs that are
distributed all over the place
or understand what is
happening in the system
by purchasing very
expensive logging systems.
You can simply rely
on the monitoring
that we provide that allows
you to see what is happening
in addition to accessing your
log seamlessly from that one
location.
And simply just focus
on your application,
the logic of your application.
And now you can easily
analyze massive data
and include that as part
of your application.
You can include
big data analytics
that rely on parallel
processing immediately.
You don't have to
learn new skill sets.
go and understand
how complicated frameworks work.
You can start today,
right away with the skill
set that you already have.
So let's discuss some
examples for that.
Log analysis.
I hope this is something
that is not new to everyone.
Certainly we can't imagine
a world without our logs.
So let's imagine that your
logs are all over the place.
And you want to do something
like click analysis.
You start by wanting to
read them from everywhere.
So if we start applying
Dataflow pipeline,
we would start by reading
from those different locations
just by pointing to them.
And then through
the pipeline, you
would apply the kind
of analysis, what kind
of information
you're looking for,
how to understand
the user experience
as they navigate
through the application.
And usually people
would run this type
of analysis every
night or every week
to optimize the application
to understand how the user
experience is working out.
But now think that you
can easily switch this
from taking the log
files to inputting
this data as a stream.
And your application
now has the opportunity
to not just understand what
the user experience is like,
but also to react to
that user experience.
You're able to decide
on the fly based
on how the user is navigating
the application, what
is the right thing
to show them next.
Right?
Well, the pipeline
can also generate
information that is
usable for reports.
So at the end, maybe
that information
is something you would like to
save in storage of some sort
where you can generate reports
like be queried for example.
Another example is data
generated by mobile phones.
Today we all have Smartphones
and they generate tons of data.
Now you can imagine
a pipeline that
is reading some information
from your mobile phone.
Something like the
GPS data for example.
And then using that data, you
can generate traffic model.
Using that traffic
model, your application
can identify where are the
areas that people actually
pass by most.
And from there, where's the
best place to open a shop?
Also you can switch
this to streaming
and apply it to an application
that not just allows
you to understand where
people are going through,
when to avoid the
most busy roads,
but also to think about
things like what's
happening right now.
So if there's a big event
where people are hanging out,
where can I go and join them?
And from there kind of
make it more interactive.
Another good example
is fraud detection.
Now fraud detection is a bit
of a more special example
because it is dealing with
sensitive information.
You're dealing with identity.
You dealing with information
about financial services.
And usually the things people
are very careful about.
So in addition to that, fraud
detection is something that
cannot happen in past tense.
You would not be able to
be very patient if you
know someone already
has got your bank
account or your identity
and are using them.
So fraud detection
is something that
has to be very interactive.
And usually the challenge
is the amount of data
that you have to do in
you're real time analysis.
But now this is all
possible because
of technologies like that.
We were talking about doing
true streaming analysis, not
micro batch or being limited
by specific amounts of data.
You can actually--
just as much data
and go to very, very
large data as much
as you like with this solution.
So with that said, if
you haven't been thinking
about big data before, maybe
it's time to think bigger.
And it's time to think of the
Cloud and how it's limitless
and makes things a lot easier.
And because they
are much easier,
naturally it's much
faster to develop.
And also, you could start
dealing with data types
you were not
naturally using before
because of the complexity
of the technology.
But now it makes
things a lot easier
for you to be able to include
it in your application.
And as you've learned
throughout I/O
from the very start
of the keynote,
we want to collaborate
with you on innovation.
So this is really how
true progress happens.
And we can't wait to see
the kind of applications
that you will build
on top of this.
We're really looking
forward to that.
And speaking of that, I want
to point you to a few more
locations where you can
get more information.
We still have events
happening in the Sandbox area
if you haven't
visited them already.
Also, if you're interested
in getting access
to these products
that we've mentioned,
first Google Cloud Dataflow
is in private testing.
You can register
for announcements.
And I recognize that the
link is very hard to see.
So I'll read it out loud.
Cloud underscore
Dataflow underscore
announce at Google Groups.
And this is a link
to be able to go
to if you would like to apply
for the private beta testing.
Additionally Pub/Sub
that we've mentioned
is already in limited preview.
So you should be able
to get it off the Cloud
at google.com/pubsub website.
And if you would like to
get started with the Cloud,
there's also special
offer you could
start over there
using this promo code.
And you would get that
much amount of credit
to play around and get a feel
for these products that are not
in limited preview on
private data testing.
But play around with
the other Cloud services
that you'd like to
get familiar with.
But all of that said,
I'd like to thank you.
We are really happy
that you could
make it today and join us.
And I hope you could see the
links better now in this light.
I will leave them up there.
And we're very happy
to take your questions.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Two questions.
First, you guys talked a
lot about the optimizations
you guys do behind the scenes.
But then in the visual, where
you show the flow of data,
it seemed to be in the
original set of code
that the developer would put in.
MARWA MABROUK: Mm-hmm.
REUVEN LAX: Yes.
And that's actually the
point of the visual console
there that even though
what we're actually
running behind the scenes is
not that code as it's written,
it's the optimized code,
we untangle it for you
and let you view it as
your code is written.
AUDIENCE: Great.
And second question,
what's the pricing of this?
MARWA MABROUK: It's
a little bit early
because we are in private
beta, to talk about pricing.
Right now, users are
showing the private beta
and naturally that doesn't
cost anything at the moment.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned Google
Cloud Storage and Pub/Sub
as input readers and writers.
I was curious what
the others are.
REUVEN LAX: As Marwa
said, this is still early.
So those are our main input
and output sources now.
But we plan on supporting more.
AUDIENCE: Can we write our own?
MARWA MABROUK: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
REUVEN LAX: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you guys talk a
little bit more about Pub/Sub.
Is this you're
thinking about this
is sort of a programmable or
governed inner input, output
layer that I can just say
who can access to this.
You can't.
How they can use the data,
whether they can read or write
it or is it much
simpler than that?
REUVEN LAX: Yes.
So you can specify access
control on Pub/Sub.
And it's a many to many.
So you configure Pub/Sub topics.
And then subscribers can
configure subscriptions
that subscribe to those topics.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about your example here.
What exactly were you omitting
on the output topic or topics?
REUVEN LAX: What I was
omitting on that output topic
from my example was exactly
what I showed in the diagram.
A set of key prefix to list
of suggestion suggestions.
I had it serialized in
JSON so my App Engine
app just subscribed to that,
listened to all these JSONs
and wrote them to
App Engine Datastore.
And then when I typed
it in the App Engine,
it just read the
suggestions back Datastore.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So you basically cached
all the output in Datastore
to be able to fetch it
easily from your app?
REUVEN LAX: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
So I was wondering what
kind of delivery guarantees
do you have both on the Pub/Sub
and actually on the processing
pipeline.
REUVEN LAX: So internal to
the processing pipeline,
we have exactly once guarantees.
So all the data
internal to the pipeline
goes through exactly once.
If you use Pub/Sub directly,
the guarantee you get
is at least once.
The data what will be delivered.
But it may try multiple
times to get it there.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Do you
guys have any numbers
that you can share
latency, SLAs or anything
like that for Pub/Sub and
for the Cloud Dataflow?
REUVEN LAX: I don't think
we have any public numbers
yet that we can share on that.
MARWA MABROUK: Yeah.
REUVEN LAX: General,
I would expect latency
on the order of seconds.
But I don't think we have
any public SLA numbers yet.
MARWA MABROUK: Yeah.
Not yet.
AUDIENCE: And then one
other question with Pub/Sub.
Traditionally the scaling
problem with Pub/Sub
is if you have one producer
that many, many consumers are
happening, like the
Beyonce problem on Twitter.
When she tweets, you have to
get it to millions of people.
What are-- do you have any
scale numbers around there
like how many messages
can be duplicated
to multiple consumers if
you're going that way?
REUVEN LAX: So we scaled
pretty well there.
So you can have many millions of
subscribers to a single topic.
No problem.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Can we combine a multiple
data source in Dataflow?
Like a batch and a stream
combining batch DataSource
and a stream DataSource
and making one result?
REUVEN LAX: So your
question is can we
combine batch and
streaming in one pipeline?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
REUVEN LAX: And the
answer is, it actually
depends on the specific
problem you're trying to solve.
Because there are
different ways to do that.
In general, yes.
But it depends on
the specific problem.
Because that could mean
different things in different
contexts.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Do we
have documentation
for say running
this on local right
now just to try a prototype?
MARWA MABROUK: So we don't
have any documentation
that is public yet.
Users who joined
the private beta
are able to see
the documentation.
We might not have
highlighted this in the talk.
But the SDK, the Java code
that Reuven was showing
runs in two modes.
One of them is in
local mode where
you're able to execute it on
your local machine pointing
to data that's accessible
from your local machine.
But that's just meant for
debugging and development.
Another mode is just
talking to the service
and submitting your workload
back into the Cloud.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Just in
terms of data types,
how well does the data pipeline,
or rather the data flow,
work with spatial
information in case
we explore on using this
for GIS applications?
REUVEN LAX: There is
so-- we are data type
agnostic in the way
that you can process
spatial information yourself.
We don't currently provide
any specific libraries
for managing spatial
information in Dataflow
if that's what you are asking.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Great.
Thank you.
REUVEN LAX: It's
pretty early as well.
REUVEN LAX: Yeah.
This is all pretty early.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I was curious if
you had done any large joins
with the data in terms
of streaming and Pub/Sub
and how you manage that.
REUVEN LAX: I'm glad you asked.
So we actually, we didn't
demo it in this pipeline,
but we do support joins
both in batch and streaming.
In streaming the joins
are often temporal joins.
So you want to join based off
of some buckling information.
In order to do a join
you essentially need to,
these key value pairs,
and you join based off
of identical keys on two
collections or two streams.
Any more questions?
MARWA MABROUK: OK.
REUVEN LAX: OK.
Thank you very much for coming.
MARWA MABROUK: Yeah.
Thank you.